c'était la maison tout le monde se
souvient l'année de l'hiver sans fin
puisque la canicule qui s'ensuivit
cette semaine là le soleil arriva enfin
et tout commença pour nous
ça vous dit de venir tuer la maison cet
après midi tout est permis il était tout
ça ni ici
ouais ma mère est partie au maroc pour
nous
elle est moche at what he won t sexy
tu réfléchis trop à la salle
et
jamais qui font une période comme ça
qu'on s'est posé un jeu des patrons au
match aller pardon je préviens c'est un
peu comme un pion vérité certaines
laquelle l'action
un peu de contrôles
jeune vague avec c'est un truc qu'on
pourrait aller ensemble ce que
c'est qu'elle est vidéos et des photos
en ligne
tu réalises que ça ça va rester sur
internet avis c'est quoi sert à part de
merde que vous avez entrepris il ya des
gamins qui font la révolution et vous
vous battez pour avoir votre baiser plus
possible pour tous